hey I'm Cameron Boyce from descendants
and you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
now that's artwork Disney Channel star
Cameron Boyce passed away in his sleep
on Saturday July 6 he was 20 years old
soon after several of his former
co-stars and friends spoke out Adam
Sandler who played his dad and grown-ups
1 & 2 tweeted this in part so much more
was on the way all our hearts are broken
thinking of your amazing family and
sending our deepest condolences Salma
Hayek who played his mom in the movie
also paid tribute sharing this on
Instagram Charles esten who played
Cameron's dad on Disney Channel's Jesse
shared a series of heartfelt tweets
including this one quote rest in peace
Cameron you will be dearly remembered my
friend and you will be greatly missed
debby ryan who starred in that series
posted these clips to her instagram
story reminding us how cameron used his
social platform for good it's crazy we
can tweet whenever we want and we can
use social media and Instagram and make
the world a better place instead of a
worse one which so many people use it
for but we need to use our resources and
what we have we're all in here in suits
we need to use what we have and make the
world a better place for other people
other people people who need us Disney
stars like Ross Lynch and Gregg Sulkin
also paid tribute to their friend Jordan
Fisher tweeted this quote love you cam
your laughter compassion and heart for
Humanity will be forever missed we are
all better for knowing you and your love
Yara Shahidi posted a lengthy message on
Instagram along with a throwback photo
while zendaya tweeted quote absolutely
heartbreaking my heart goes out to his
friends and family camera and perhaps
known best for his work in Disney's
descendants was getting ready for the
release of the third and final
installment next month
and while his co-stars like booboo
Stewart dove Cameron and Sophia Carson
haven't said anything about Cameron's
death just yet their director Kenny
Ortega has quote may the love and let
you spread throughout your life sore you
with flight into the heavens above you
are already an angel in life the legacy
you leave is magnificent love you my
forever boy and so has Chyna mcclain
with this heartbreaking post I lost my
best friend
my closest friend my longest friend I'll
never again have a friend like Cameron
[Music]
you